[Music]
waking up every day first thing you're
thinking about is this still
moko zombie is life in trinidad tv
[Music]
the tradition of moko jumbi is a special
form of stilt walking named after a west
african spirit who watches over villages
thanks to his towering height
in times of celebration groups of
trinidadian dancers pay tribute to this
spirit but for adrian moko jumbi is part
of his everyday life
my name is adrianian and i've been
walking still for 21 years
the highest i walked is 10 feet
my dance group is called future jumbies
and it's a school for anyone to learn to
walk stills
there are various ways you put on your
stairs
we got our shoes attached and then we
have our knee brace we tie up strap up
and then we can have someone raise us up
we train starting on one footsteps
and then they gradually go up
you have to overcome the fear of falling
falling is good
if you fall you learn nothing
no risk no reward
these are the dance moves on sticks
we got limbo
stoop
lara
butterfly
and the moko train
the hardest move is the air split that's
where you take your foot and split in
here
my favorite part of moko zombie dancing
is
when my whole team that i trained just
killing it
i feel that joy that didn't doing
nothing
when i see my team giving it their all
and doing their routines i feel a sense
of pride and sometimes feel like sharing
a tear
one of our sons are bringing everyone
together
[Music]
i think a lot of people look at hula as
just women dancing but
we love it man
hula is a story
to tell the story the way the ancient
hawaiians did
you really need to put yourself in that
dance you need to live like them you
need to chant like them
you need to train like them
basically you need to become them
in ancient times
warriors are actually recruited from the
halau chief would come to look
from the ranks of the advanced male
dancers
warriors were selected
the philosophy of our halau is to kind
of replicate
that we're basically telling warrior
stories and to dance like a warrior you
need to train like a warrior
[Music]
we train in a private piece of land on
the west side of oahu using only what
ancient hawaiians had
whether it's rocks the sand
the ocean
when we come to practice we expect to
die
it's strenuous on the legs but it's also
to train your mind
i tell myself and the rest of the boys
if i fall it's because my body just gave
out
[Music]
one of the hardest workouts we do would
be climbing the coconut tree
sometimes you reach the top and your
legs are shaking because you know you're
holding your weight
and to look down
knowing that nothing's holding you you
gotta kind of have this warrior mindset
as like you know that this is what i
want you know i'm gonna get this
[Music]
you know when these gentlemen come to
hula
they're like a ball of clay
as kumu
i look at it as my responsibility to
shape them into better individuals
better fathers better sons better
brothers
our goal is that when these men are done
dancing
that they leave here better people
[Music]
what hula does for me culturally it
still takes me back to to hawaii used to
be
people sometimes are losing that aloha
for each other that love for each other
and hula just gives you that reality
check man
i'm dancing until my kneecaps fall off
and even after that i'm gonna do
whatever i can for the halau
you know we have this brotherhood where
we take care of each other
we help push each other
it's my passion and i look forward to
seeing where hula takes me in life
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
my
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
dancing is not only being on stage and
performing but is telling a story
and by telling your stories you change
the world
[Music]
my name is masavata state i'm a
performing artist particular pantolo
tensor
peninsula is a tent and it was
originated in south african townships
it's very energetic and fast paced type
of events
and it always goes with the bead
everything has to be on point and we all
go up and down at the same time same
pace and also poinsula is a culture
it involves the dress code
the lifestyle
the language and the dance itself
from head to toe it was to
indicate that we are saying
the chosen course from jail most panzula
people were jailed for
different reasons
pansula was a response to the apartheid
negative we wanted to fight back to get
our freedom back
whenever we tend to express how we feel
so every time when we express our
feelings we become free
after it was developed it was more of to
compete and the crews were competing
with each other by the end of the day
they will know who's the winner
but now we are doing it as a way of
living in a career
pantula even when it was developed it
was nail dominant dance when i attended
the competition it was only men it was
never easy for women to keep up with the
dance
the ladies glue that i'm dancing with is
called a verb we were challenged
to do like guys do it the same energy
the same power and everything
[Music]
yeah the kicks that i've got as a dancer
is to be part of the music video for my
keva by jay
the other one is to be part of cho vito
tv drama
[Music]
i'm working to expand the culture in
penzola
i feel honored
to be presenting the peninsula as a
whole
i'm 27 years old and i've been dancing
since i was young
when i tense it allows me to express how
i feel it gives me that freedom
[Music]
[Applause]
venezuela
[Music]
el claude
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
santa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you